this video is brought to you by appsuma
the leading digital Marketplace for
entrepreneurs
hi
welcome to another episode of Cold
Fusion where I cover anything in science
technology business or history
imagine a device fraught with such
complexity that it caused an Apple
employee to sadly end his own life and
caused another employee to end up in
prison this happened in the early 1990s
with the Apple Newton project a mobile
device with a touch screen and apps
Apple was looking to start a revolution
but all they got was failure and
personal disaster behind the scenes so
what happened why did the Newton fail
and what can be learned sit back and get
comfortable as we take a look into
Apple's greatest failure
you are watching cold fusion TV
[Music]
in 1992 Apple then known as Apple
computer was a completely different
place to what it is today
Steve Jobs had been forced out of the
company seven years earlier in 1985 and
John Scully previously of PepsiCo was at
the helm he was a master of marketing
but didn't know much about technology a
fact that would prove disastrous later
Apple itself hadn't produced a hit
product since the original Macintosh in
1985 and the company needed its next big
break
the 1990s was an odd time for technology
a place before the smartphone and
mainstream internet but it was also a
time after home Computing had been well
established the hottest new idea for
technology at the time was the personal
digital assistant or PDA its aim was
mainly to organize schedule and plan the
first true PDA was released in 1991 by
Passion the next year in 1992 Apple
would venture into this product category
the original idea for the Newton came
from Apple engineer Steve Zuckerman he
had some previous experiences in
portable technology after building the
HP 110 the world's first battery-powered
Microsoft based PC and it was released
in 1984. in Sacramento's view there was
a hidden future beyond the PC
Steve Jobs liked what Sacrament had done
with the HP portable computer and would
hire him at Apple to create a portable
version of the Macintosh in 1984.
[Music]
the next year however Steve Jobs was
forced out of apple and without the
guidance of jobs Sacrament became
disillusioned with an apple he was
reduced to overseeing the hardware teams
for the Apple II and Macintosh product
lines he was tempted to leave apple as
he was bored with the work but fellow
Apple employee Jean-Louis Garcia
convinced sacrament to build a team
within Apple to experiment with new
ideas
in 1987 the team was approved and the
group would grow quickly
Steve suckerman gathered a team of
Engineers and moved into an abandoned
warehouse in Cupertino they got to work
brainstorming and building
the new device for now in their
imagination would be called the Apple
Newton reason being the original Apple
logo was Isaac Newton sitting under a
tree so the name Newton made sense
the Newton researchers began work on an
ipad-like device
Steve seckerman envisioned the tablet
computer the size of a folded A4 sheet
of paper the price was to be the same as
a desktop computer at the time
being aware of all the developments
going on in Tech at the time he
Incorporated touch screens and
recognition a hard disk and even an
infrared Port so Newtons could
communicate with each other wirelessly
separately Apple upper management had
been toying with a similar idea CEO John
Scully commissioned two high-budget
video mock-ups of a product called the
knowledge Navigator in 1986. here's a
sample
[Music]
let me see the election notes from last
semester
no that's not enough I need to review
more recent literature pull up all the
new articles I haven't read yet Journal
articles only
fine your friend Jill Gilbert has
published an article about deforestation
in the Amazon excuse me Jill Gilbert is
calling back great put her through hi
Mike what's up is this one of your
typical last minute panics for lecture
material you would be great if you were
available to make a few comments nothing
formal
you know I have a simulation that shows
the spread of the Sahara over the last
20 years here let me show you
nice very nice I've got some maps of the
Amazon area during the same time let's
put these together
interesting I can definitely use this
thanks for your time Jill I really
appreciate it no problem
right see
bye-bye
while you were busy your mother called
again to remind you to pick up the
birthday cake fine fine
um princess article before I go
now printing
okay I'm going to lunch now
unfortunately for the Newton team the
reality of late 1980s technology didn't
really live up to the dream prototype
tablets had major issues handwriting
recognition just didn't work different
writing styles were proving impossible
for the device to understand and with
handwriting being the primary input
method for the device this was a
disaster eventually the software wasn't
proved a little but still needed a large
amount of work
meanwhile apple as a company was still
doing okay but was becoming over-reliant
on the sales of the Macintosh computer
to make matters worse compact Gateway
and Dell were all on the rise with only
less than 10 of the Computing Market
things were going to get a whole lot
worse for Apple perhaps the Newton being
a completely new product category was
just the thing Apple needed to turn
things around
meanwhile a second team with an apple
was also working on a portable device
called the pocket Crystal it had three
processors a battery that lasted for
weeks at a time and weighed at eight
pounds or 3.6 kilograms
however the cost will be 8 000 US
dollars
due to separate internal struggle
Sacrament left Apple in 1990 the project
would continue though under the
leadership of Larry Tesla formerly of
Xerox Park he was impressed by the
Newton and provided a detailed
demonstration to Apple's upper
management in 1991. John Scully loved
the idea and decided to run with it over
the pocket Crystal interestingly the
pocket Crystal would later spin out into
a separate company called General magic
a company that almost invented an
iphone-like device but failed just at
the last moment
this may be a story for another episode
so it was 1991. Scully had the
Revolutionary product that was going to
save Apple a tablet computer with a
touch screen although the screen was
resistive touch and had no multi-touch
capabilities it was to be revolutionary
for its time
such a device Was A New Concept so the
team argued about what size it should be
the original plan was to have three
models a 9 by 12 inch model costing
about five thousand dollars and then a
six by nine inch model costing 2 000 and
a 4.5 by 7 inch costing 500. after much
arguing it was decided that the smaller
size would be the best option John
Scully would make a plan for the Newton
to ship in April of 1992 a tight
deadline by any standard he was so
excited that he didn't wait for the
development to finish before announcing
it to the public in January of 1992. he
made the announcement at the Consumer
Electronics Show in Las Vegas
a public demo would be held in Chicago a
few months later
Scully while being able to sell the idea
of the Newton didn't understand the
intricacies of getting the device
consumer ready so the Apple Engineers
got to work and work they did they were
trying to kill thousands of bucks during
this time 15 to 20 hour days weren't
uncommon
as development continued it became clear
that the processor wasn't going to be
powerful enough to keep up with the
software demands so they decided to
switch to an arm processor luckily for
them it turned out both to be faster and
more efficient at running code
they were far from being in the clear
though as the demo Drew closer the
Newton was still unreliable units would
sometimes get too hot to handle because
of faulty power managers
as the team practiced demonstrations of
key features like faxing and beaming
information wirelessly via infrared the
Newton would fail more often than it
succeeded
the big day arrived in Chicago and apple
showed off their latest device now
called the Newton message pad all of the
message pads were Tethered to Max they
were just too unreliable to run
independently
the engineers demonstrated some shape
recognition and showed off the user
interface
press was a light with excitement and to
them it seemed like the Newton was ready
to ship
but behind the scenes the device was far
from being done
for the Apple Engineers there was a sigh
of relief but then a slow realization
that this had become the ultimate
pressure cooker situation
as development continued more problems
arose getting the Newton consumer ready
was proving to be a massive challenge
the release date was pushed back to
August 1993. the Press became unhappy
about this and labeled the device
vaporware
the company would showcase the product
again at the Consumer Electronics Show
in 1993 this time without tethering to a
Macintosh
[Music]
in an effort to get the product ready
countless weeks of 16-hour days took its
toll on many of the Apple employees
working on the Newton project some quit
and others simply cried relationships
suffered and mental health was left in
the dust
according to the New York Times as the
deadline closed in 30 year old software
engineer Co essono couldn't take it
anymore and sadly took his own life in
December of 1992.
[Music]
within a week another programmer had a
breakdown ending up in prison after
attacking his roommate
for those of you who have seen the
making of the iPhone documentary all of
this pressure would ring a bell
due to these tragic events Apple would
introduce a buddy mental health program
and this was to help Engineers who were
on the verge of burning out from intense
work
even a day before the next Consumer
Electronics Show Newtons were failing
without warning and the batteries were
getting eaten alive by faulty power
management the team was not confident in
their success but miraculously
everything worked as planned on the day
as the software moved into beta in May
almost 4 000 bucks were found most of
these were sorted by the end of the
month but it was still too buggy to ship
staff were pushed even harder than ever
before
finally despite all of this the Newton
message pad rolled out in August of 1993
at Mac world
by this point much of the original hype
had died down as it was over a year past
its original launch date
it had also promised too much the
wireless features which were a major
selling point didn't make it at launch
selling for 6.99 the first version of
the Newton could recognize printed and
handwritten text it had a library of a
thousand words and could learn more like
a modern smartphone does today
[Music]
because of the buggy software the early
press sentiment wasn't positive even The
Simpsons would make a mockery of the
handwriting recognition hey Draft take a
member on your Newton beat up Martin
although there was an on-screen keyboard
handwriting was the primary method of
interfacing with the device so buggy
text recognition was less than ideal
by 1995 in a newer version called the
message pad 120 a lot of these software
bugs were fixed in 1997 Apple would spin
off the Newton division into a new
company they would be in charge of
selling the best version yet the message
pad 2000 it had a relatively quick 166
megahertz processor a larger 2 megabytes
of removable storage one megabyte of RAM
and a higher 480p resolution display
and though the screen would still be
hard to read at times it would be a
modest success it finally looked like
the Newton would be the future direction
of Apple the Newton company even got
their own logo Apple employees and even
a separate board of directors
Apple was losing money in 1997. So the
plan was to gain outside investment into
the new Newton company
the Standalone Newton company would go
public in 1999. it wasn't to be though
as soon as Steve Jobs took back control
of Apple in 1998 he made the decision to
cut the Newton project completely Steve
Jobs wanted to focus the company's
efforts in a more concentrated and
cohesive Direction
in its Five Years on the market the
Newton only sold around 200 000 units
for comparison in its first five years
the iPhone sold over 130 million units
although it was clear that there was
something to be said for mobile
Computing back then it was perhaps too
early and too ambitious
looking back from the future it's easy
to see that web browsing would have been
the killer app for the Newton but the
first commercial web browser was only
released in 1993. while the Newton was
being made there really was no vision of
what mobile web browsing could look like
it just didn't really exist at the time
interestingly a mobile web browser
called Hopper was made for the later
versions of the Newton but it was too
little too late
ultimately the Newton was a product in
search for a problem to solve it was too
expensive for casual buyers but too
underpowered for business users the
Newton's Legacy does live on as the
great grandfather to all smartphones and
also its popularization of the arm
processor
before we continue I just want to give a
shout out to today's sponsor appsumo as
creators and entrepreneurs we wear a lot
of hats social media project management
sales accounting copywriting just to
name a few appsumo is the leading
digital Marketplace for entrepreneurs
and the best way to automate the busy
work that comes from running a business
last Black Friday appsumo gave away a
Tesla and this year they're taking their
one million dollar Black Friday budget
and giving it away to any Creator he
lists a product on appsuma there's also
an additional ten thousand dollars for
ten randomly chosen lucky creators list
your product on appsumo before November
the 17th and grab your share of their 1
million Black Friday marketing fund plus
a chance to be one of 10 lucky winners
randomly chosen to win an additional ten
thousand dollars
so in summary ultimately three things
doomed the Newton number one early
negative press number two a lack of
internet connectivity and number three a
CEO who didn't deeply understand the
technology he was touting or just how
much work it would take to bring it to
life in a polished way the Newton team
recognized the loss of 30 year old Mr
isono in which the pressure of the
project contributed to him ending his
life if you type in a special command
the Newton screen will say in memory of
Co assono the Newton story is one of
dedication personal sacrifice and a
product that was too early promising too
much while delivering too little in the
world of technology timing is everything
if we include the mental toll that it
took on Apple's staff and the tragic
loss of Mr esono the Apple Newton was
without a doubt Apple's greatest failure
because all of this effort went into a
project that was immediately scrapped
with the return of Steve Jobs
so what do you guys think
let me know in the comment section below
if you want to discuss this video head
on over to the cold fusion Discord if
you want to see a similar episode on the
development of the iPhone and the behind
the scenes pressure that went on I'll
leave a link to that cold fusion episode
below as well
anyway that's it from me my name is [ __ ]
and you've been watching cold fusion and
I'll catch you again soon for the next
episode cheers guys have a good one
[Music]